J. MICHAL MCBRIDE: The idea is
that if you're
talking about two similar
reactions, two similar reagents,
the one that's more
reactive will be less
selective in
which product it gives.
So here we have the example of
two radicals, a chlorine or
bromine atom, reacting with
propane.
Remember, the chain reaction is
that first the halogen atom
pulls off a hydrogen, generates
a radical, which
then takes on a new halogen.
So wherever that first hydrogen
gets pulled off,
that's where the halogen will
end up in the product.
But in the case of propane there
are two different
hydrogens that you can take
off-- the one in the middle or
the one at the end.
And it's easier to take off the
one in the middle because
the radical is more stable, the
secondary radical, the
internal one rather than the
primary radical.
We talked about that last time--
the extent to which
that's true.
But whether it's differences in
the starting material or
differences in the product,
however you slice it, it's
easier to take off the hydrogen
from the secondary
position than the primary
position.
So the overall heat of the
reaction as you see here is
better by 2.5 kilocalories for
generating the secondary
radical, as opposed to
generating the primary radical.
And that's true whether chlorine
is doing the
abstracting or bromine is doing
the abstracting.
The same difference overall in
the products.
But the actual change in energy
is much more positive
in the case of bromine.
It's harder to do than it is in
chlorine.
So chlorine is more reactive and
bromine is less reactive.
But notice that the difference
in the activation energies is
more dramatic in the case of
bromine than it is in the case
of chlorine.
The earlier the transition
comes, the less difference
there's going to be.
So chlorine, the more reactive
reagent, is less selective.
And bromine, the less reactive
agent, is more selective.
So this is called the
reactivity-selectivity
principle, and it only can apply
to the extent that the
transition states are mirroring
what the products do
and that the two reactions are
very, very similar to one
another, and there's not
something else that makes the
reaction transition state come
much earlier or much later
with a much different structure.
So in the case of chlorine, the
relative rate of forming
secondary versus primary is a
factor of 4.
But in the case of bromine it's
almost 10 times as large,
the selectivity. It's a factor
of 35.
That means in the first case,
the difference in energies of
activation, the delta delta G
double-dagger--
delta G double-dagger is the
activation energy.
But the difference in the
activation energy is 0.8
kilocalories per mole, about 1.
Whereas with the later
transition state the
difference is very much bigger,
4.5.
So typically more reactive means
less selective.
So if you were a chemist who
wanted to prepare a certain
product that required
selectivity, you might choose
to use a less reactive reagent
rather than a more reactive
one, so you'd get a higher yield
of the material you wanted,
even if it was a little more
difficult to do, if it took a
little longer.
Now let's look at this a little
more carefully, the
fact that the difference in
energies of activation in the
case of bromine taking off a
primary or a secondary
hydrogen, the difference in
activation is 4.5
kilocalories per mole.
We just went through why it was
reasonable that
it should be large.
But should it be that large?
Notice that the difference when
you get all the way to
products is 2.5 kilocalories per
mole.
Now we had the idea that
relative to a standard, say
methane, the energies for taking
off a secondary
hydrogen should be--
either the starting material is
less stable or the product
is more stable, compared to our
standard
methane in this case.
But at any rate, there's an
increase in stability relative
to the normal case, up at the
top here.
Relative to that, there's an
increase in stability as you
go from starting material to
this free-radical
intermediate.
Now there's a question where the
transition
state comes on that.
If it's early you don't see much
of
that increased stability.
If it comes late you see more of
that stability difference.
However, you see what's nuts
here?
What we see is this.
There's more difference at the
transition state than there
even is when you get all the way
to product.
So how can the transition states
be more different in
energy than the products are?
This might not be a straight
line, but at least you'd
expect it to be monotonic--
not go down and then up again.
There's something we're missing
here.
The trouble we're having is
understanding the energy of
transition states.
Regular molecules we're more or
less comfortable with, but
transition states are tougher.
So one way to look at transition
states is molecular
orbital theory.
Another one is with resonance
theory.
And the problem is that you
don't know which of the R or
Br the hydrogen is bonded to
when it's being transferred.
You could write one resonance
structure in which it's bonded
to R and bromine is an atom.
Or you could write another
resonance structure where it's
bonded to Br and R is the free
radical.
And it's exactly poised between
those two at the
transition state-- that's the
definition of the transition
state that you're about halfway
there.
But what's special about the
transition state if there
could be another resonance
structure.
A third resonance structure,
which has Br minus, because
bromine, after all, is
electronegative.
And R could be plus.
So at the transition state here
we could have cation
character to the R, so that will
be helpful at the
transition state.
A third resonance structure here
stabilizing things in
resonance theory.
But the R cation is irrelevant
when it's R-H over here, or
when it's an R radical.
Once the radical gets away it
only has a
certain number of electrons.
It's not R plus anymore.
So as we'll see next week,
substituting a methyl for
hydrogen that is going from a
primary to a secondary cation
stabilizes the cation a lot.
So this is unusually stable.
But this is important, this
resonance structure, only at
the transition state--
not in the starting material and
not in the product.
So we make a mistake in this
case if we assume that the
character of the transition
state is intermediate between
starting material and product
for this one-step reaction.
There are actually special
factors that apply only in the
transition state.
And we'll see when we talk about
pericyclic reactions
that this is very important.
So sometimes factors involved in
stabilizing transition
states could be different from
those involved in stabilizing
either the starting materials or
the products.
And in these cases we can't
easily rationalize the
activation energy changes on the
basis of the overall
exothermicity or endothermicity
of the reaction
step, because there's something
special going on at
the transition state.
You hope that's not always the
case.
Most cases you could do thinking
that more exothermic
reactions will be faster.
But you have to be careful in
some cases.
And as I said, we'll see
dramatic examples where the
transition state has something
special about it when we get
to discussing pericyclic
reactions in the third quarter
of the course.
Now here are two problems for
Wednesday that have to do with
free-radical substitution, and
you can work in
groups if you wish.
Remember, we won't have a class
on Monday, and there
won't be discussion section in
the evening on Monday either.
So here's problem one.
Suppose, as we've just been
talking about,
monochlorination of propane
gives n-propyl chloride and
isopropyl chloride in ratio
43:57.
Note I say monochlorination,
because, of course, these
products can also have a
hydrogen abstracted and you
can get dichlorination,
trichlorination and so on.
So if you want to get these
ratios accurately, you do just
a little bit of reaction and see
the first products before
you get subsequent substitutions
on the initial products.
You do just a little conversion
and see
what the ratio is.
And in the case of propane it's
43:57, primary and
secondary with the hydrogen
places.
So if that, and if
monochlorination of
2-methylpropane gives--
it's called isobutane also--
gives t-butyl chloride and
1-chloro-2-methylpropane, 36%
and 64% yields.
Notice this is a little test
also on knowing what the
structures are of compounds that
have these names.
Then predict the products for
monochlorination of
2-methylbutane.
So you're going to get relative
reactivity of primary
and secondary from one, relative
and tertiary from another, and
then you'll use the relative
reactivity of secondary and
tertiary to solve the problem.
Now you'll find in the textbooks
that you have--
every textbook I'm confident has
this kind of problem in it
about selectivity in free-
radical chlorination.
It probably has the same
examples.
So consult your textbook on
free-radical halogenation to
be sure you're taking the
statistics of hydrogen numbers
properly into account.
That's the first problem.
The second problem is solve the
puzzle that's going to be
coming up on slide 18, so hold
on and we'll get to that one.
So we've been talking about
free- radical substitution--
take off a hydrogen and
substitute it with a halogen.
But there's another free-radical
chain reaction that
involves halogens, and that's
addition to alkenes.
So the starting materials are an
alkene and hydrogen halide.
And somehow you get a radical to
start it off,
say a halogen radical.
And instead of pulling off a
hydrogen it adds
to the double bond.
So it gives that intermediate
carbon radical.
And then that one is the one
that does an abstraction of
hydrogen, this time from H-X. So
you get a product where X
and H have added to the
carbon-carbon double bond.
So free-radical addition to the
alkenes, and
it's a chain reaction.
Once you get a radical it can go
round and round without
getting rid of radicals.
Let's look at the energetics
that are involved in this.
A curious thing about this
reaction is it doesn't work
with all X-H's.
Now let's see why.
So we'll analyze the energies of
the bonds-- we're using
here just average bond energies.
So in the starting material we
have a carbon-carbon double
bond that's worth 146.
And we have the X radical, and
also there's X-H in the
starting material.
And in the product we've added
the X-H to the alkene making a
new carbon-carbon bond that's
worth 83 kilocalories per
mole, and a carbon-hydrogen bond
that's worth 99.
And we've converted X-H to X
radical.
So if we look at the average
bond energies involving
fluorine, for R-X, the product,
we have 116 that's
going to go in here.
And a starting material we're
going to have H-X,
hydrogen-fluoride, 135 that's
going to go there.
So we're going to add these
together, these bond energies.
Here it's 146 for the double
bond, and 135 for the X-H in
the case of fluorine.
And in the product, it's going
to be 83 and 99 and 116 for
the carbon-fluorine bond.
So we add them together and we
find out this is favorable by
17 kilocalories per mole to do
the overall transformation.
So it's going to be exothermic
in the case of HF.
How about in the case of the
other halogen atoms?
We could use the corresponding
values for their bonds, and we
get that they're almost exactly
the same.
So all these additions would be
the same exothermicity.
So you might think they'd all go
at about the same rate.
But they don't at all.
Only HBr works.
Why?
Overall, the thermodynamics is
fine for the transformation.
But the question is mechanism
and activation energies.
And remember there are two steps
in this reaction.
First the X adds to the alkene,
then the new carbon
radical abstracts a hydrogen.
So we have to look at the
individual steps to get what
the activation energies are.
So we first have to go to this
intermediate, which has a
single bond worth 83
kilocalories per mole, instead
of the double bond worth 146.
So that's going to be fabulously
exothermic, this
first step.
So very exothermic should mean
very fast, so that's going to
be no problem.
That's in the case of fluorine,
the blue one.
In the case of chlorine it's
still exothermic--
that should be not as fast but
easy still.
Bromine still exothermic.
But iodine is endothermic.
So that reaction is going to be
very slow.
So we can understand now why
iodine doesn't work.
But why not fluorine and why not
chlorine?
STUDENT: Because the second part
isn't favored...
PROFESSOR: Ah, Derek, you're
right.
It's the second step that's hard
for them.
Because having this intermediate
we now have to go
here by abstracting the X-H
bond.
And the X-H bond we have to
break in the case of fluorine
is fabulously strong, 135
kilocalories per mole.
So that reaction is going to be
way endothermic and it'll
be very slow.
So the cyclic mechanism will
cough on the second
step for that one.
And in the case of chlorine the
second step is also a
little bit endothermic so it's
not very fast.
But in the case of bromine it's
exothermic again.
In the case of iodine it would
be exothermic, but the first
step is where the machine
coughed.
So only bromine is set up to do
both of
these relatively rapidly.
Now you might say, OK, we'll do
the others,
we'll just wait longer.
It won't be as fast because one
or the other the steps
will be slow.
We'll just wait.
But you can't do that with
free-radical reactions.
Only HBr works fast enough in
both steps, and you need both
steps to be fast.
Now we're going to get to
discussing what would happen
otherwise, if both steps aren't
fast, in just a minute.
But first I want to comment on
one other aspect of addition
to the alkenes.
What's called regiospecificity.
I don't particularly like that
word, but it has to do with
when you add HX to a double bond
there are two regions
they could go to-- the H could
go here and the X
here or vice versa.
So when we add HX we could
imagine X going to this carbon
or H going to this carbon.
And it turns out that for any
halogen that can undergo
addition, there's a principle
called "Markovnikov
orientation", after a Russian
chemist at the latter part of
the nineteenth century.
And he discovered this in 1870,
just about the time that
people knew about structures, of
course, that what you
tended to get was the more
substituted halide, that is
the X went to the carbon between
these two that has
more substituents on it.
And it's understood in terms of
initial addition of H+.
This was figured out in the
1930s.
And it's because of this ionic
mechanism that we'll discuss
in three weeks that Markovnikov
orientation works.
We'll talk about that when we
come to it.
But what's important is when you
do this HBr addition by
the free radical mechanism, the
cyclic mechanism, you get
the anti-Markovnikov product.
It goes exactly the other way--
the bromine goes on the
less substituted carbon.
So this was quite a mystery for
people from 1870 on, why
HBr was sometimes a bad actor.
Sometimes it would give the
Markovnikov product, the
expected one that all the other
hydrogen
halides would give.
But sometimes it gave the other.
It tended not to give mixtures,
it would give all
one or all the other.
But in the 1930s, 1933, it was
found out that this happened
when the samples contained
little bits of peroxide.
Now let's see why that is.
It's because it's an initiator
of radical chains.
Remember you needed some way to
have a radical to begin
this whole process.
So if you have R-O-O-R, a
peroxide, and HBr and the
alkene, the first thing that
happens in this mechanism is
that you break the O-O bond to
get two R-O radicals.
Now you have the radical that
could do a hydrogen
abstraction.
So it abstracts hydrogen from
HBr, and now
you're into the machine--
you have X dot that could add to
the alkene and get one or
the other of those two radicals.
Now if you've got the radical on
the left you get
Markovnikov orientation, because
H would come here the
next time it abstracts H from
HBr.
But, in fact, this is the one
you get because the secondary
radical is more stable.
So when you're getting radicals
you get that one
rather than the primary radical.
So that explains then the
regiospecificity of the
special addition of HBr, but
only if you
can get free radicals.
Now why can't you just do it
waiting longer?
This has to do with the rate law
when you
have a catalytic cycle.
So we're going to discuss it in
this case, but it's
important in all sorts of cases
where there's catalysis
in inorganic chemistry, in
biochemistry.
When there's catalysis and you
have these cycles, the rate
laws you get are a little bit
different from
what you might expect.
So there are two steps in this
reaction.
The first step has a certain
rate constant and, of course,
the rate then multiplies that
rate constant by
concentrations to get a rate.
And the two reagents are R-H and
X dot.
Then there's the second step
which has some other rate
constant, K2, and its starting
materials are, in this case,
that dihalogen and R dot.
Now a couple of years ago when
we were having a visiting
lecture by Barry Sharpless who
won the Nobel Prize in
catalysis--
you can look at his lecture if
you want to-- but one thing he
said caught my imagination.
He said, "This is a real
democracy, catalysis".
What did he mean by it being a
democracy?
It's because when this thing is
going around, these two
rates have to be equal.
Whatever K1 times those is has
to equal K2 times those.
And the concentration of the
free radicals will adjust the
ratio of the two to make those
two equal.
What would happen if the first
one were really fast and the
second one were slow?
Then you would convert X dot to
R dot.
So you'd have a big R dot, which
would favor the second
one, and the small X dot on the
first one, and soon they'd
become equal and then the thing
can go around at
whatever rate they allow.
But both steps are involved.
These two things become equal.
So that's what he meant by a
democracy
that they were equal.
Now you can see an example of
that if you look down on the
Garden State Parkway here.
Notice that for the cars going
north there's a lot of
difference between these lanes
of traffic and
these lanes of traffic.
And the same is true here.
There's a big difference between
those two.
And the reason is that this is
cash and this is E-ZPass.
So if we look just at the cash
lanes, you notice that there's
a low rate constant here.
You've got lots of starting
material building up its
concentration trying to get
through paying.
But once they get through they
can accelerate and go on fine.
So here you have a high rate
constant, here you have a low
rate constant.
But the number of cars per
minute, the fluxes here and
here, are the same.
The cars that come here also end
up here.
So the point is that here you
have high concentration, here
you have low concentration.
But the rates are the same.
The small rate constant paying
cash times the high
concentration is the same as the
big rate constant once you
speed it up times the low
concentration.
So it's the same as you go
around in the cycle.
The rates of the two have to be
the same, even though the
rate constants are different.
So the concentrations adjust.
And you'll notice, as Sharpless
said in that
lecture, if there's a slow step,
like this one, then
there's 99.9% of the titanium is
what he was calling about--
remember we talked about that
last time.
That's what he was talking
about.
They're stuck before this big
mountain that goes way up like
Mount Everest, he said.
He's a colorful speaker.
If you get that barrier down
then the rate goes way up.
And if you get them all at the
same height then
you're really rolling.
So notice that's what happens in
the E-ZPass lane, that they
go at the same rate because
you've gotten that first big
rate constant up, the barrier
down, for that first step.
Now let's apply that principle
back to this catalytic cycle.
So we had from the previous
slide that these two had to be
equal when the machine is
running.
Now suppose K1 is small and K2
is large.
So now how does the rate, the
amount of material you produce
per minute, depend on the
concentration of R-H?
Well, we can look here.
We could rearrange this to say
that the ratio of X dot to R
dot is K2 times X2 over K1 times
R-H. That we get by just
dividing through.
So we know the ratio of these
two.
But the total of the two,
there's a certain amount of
radical there.
As you go around the cycle it
could be either in the form of
X dot or in the form of R dot.
So the ratio can change, but the
total amount is limited.
So let us suppose that X dot is
dominant.
Suppose there's 98:2, the ratio
of X dot to R dot.
Now let's double the amount of
R-H. We're leaving the
radicals the same but we're
doubling the amount of R-H. So
we're going to double this,
double this, leave that the
same, these are fixed constants,
but
we're doubling this.
So what's going to happen?
The ratio's going to change.
That's what we've just been
talking about.
So instead of 98:2, we have to
get a ratio that's
only half that big.
We have 100 radicals to deal
with.
They're in the form of 98 X dot
and 2 R dot.
If we double R-H, up here--
we're interested in what that
exponent is-- we double R-H,
we're going to halve that ratio.
How will we do it?
We still have 100 radicals.
But instead of 98:2, if we
assume that the sum is
constant, we're going to have
96:4.
Everybody see that?
This ratio is half that ratio,
very close.
But how much did that change the
concentration of X dot?
Notice it doubled the
concentration of R dot.
But it hardly changed the
concentration of X dot at all
in relative terms. it just went
to 96 from 98.
So X dot is still the same
concentration.
So the rate at which you go
through here, which is the
same as the rate you go through
here, is
now the same here.
This one has been doubled, and
this one is practically the
same-- it's 96 instead of 98.
So what happened to the rate
approximately? Matt?"
STUDENT: Doubled?
PROFESSOR: The rate doubled.
So who's surprised that when you
double the starting
material here you double the
rate?
That is that the question mark
there is about 2.
I see no hands.
What do you expect?
So this rate grows by that now,
1.96 fold, practically 2.
So it's first order in R-H. Did
I say 2 before?
It's first order in R-H, no
one's surprised.
Of course, the rate is also
proportional to K1.
Now how about if we change the
concentration of X2?
What's its exponent?
So let's do the same analysis.
Now we're going to double X2.
So we'll double X2 and now we're
going to have to double
the ratio of X dot to R dot.
Remember we're starting from 98
to 2.
What do we do in order to double
that ratio?
We have to go 99 to 1.
Everybody see that?
That's now going to make a
difference because if we look
at this rate, which is the same
as that rate, it's the
same K2, the same--
pardon me, we doubled X2.
But R dot is now only half as
big as it was before.
So we doubled X2, but we halved
R dot.
So we didn't accelerate it at
all.
So it's zero order in X2.
So it depends on the
concentration of this starting
material, the one that goes into
the slow step, but it
doesn't depend on the
concentration of this starting
material, the one that goes into
the fast step.
So probably if I'd asked you, my
guess is if--
we should have done this as a
democracy, as Sharpless said.
And I should have asked you
before what you think that
exponent is and what you think
that exponent is.
My guess is you'd have said
they're both 1.
But in fact that one's zero.
The rate is also, therefore, if
it's insensitive to X2 it's
also insensitive to K2.
So in summary, when one step of
a cycle is much slower than
the others, the rate of cycling
is pretty insensitive
to the rate constant and
concentration of the incoming
reagent for the fast step.
Because concentration of the
minor form of recycling
reagent adjust to compensate and
fractional changes in
concentrations of dominant
radical are much more modest.
So the rate's obviously going to
be proportional, to the
amount of radical.
There's no surprises--
if you were running 13 machines
it's going to be 13
times faster than running just
one machine.
But that's the other factor that
we were going to get to a
few minutes ago.
That we're going to have
initiation and termination,
and in my fancying up the slides
I forgot to animate
that properly, sorry.
So initiation typically involves
breaking a weak bond
with light, heat or adding an
electron, or sometimes taking
away an electron.
So heat, you can take a weak
bond, and with heat, break it
to get two radicals--
the oxygen-oxygen bond is
unusually weak, as we're going
to be discussing not long from
now.
Or you can use light-- we talked
about this last
semester already--
take an electron that's in
sigma, put it in sigma-star
and the chlorines will come
apart.
This one has an energy of 30
kilocalories per mole.
What are the energies of other
sigma bonds we've been talking
about, more or less?
C-C or C-H, for example, order
of magnitude.
100, right?
3 times as strong.
So this is an unusually weak
bond, so you
can do it with heat.
And the reason it's weak is
because you have repulsion
among these unshared pairs of
electrons that you don't have
in the other cases.
We'll talk about that in just a
minute as well.
Or you can put an electron into
sigma-star by a reduction
reaction and get OH minus, but
the free radical OH, which can
do a hydrogen abstraction and
start the chain.
But even if you're generating
radicals, you could lose by
radicals being destroyed.
Remember we said why not just
wait longer and let this
machine go around, even if it's
going slower?
The reason is that's not all the
radicals can do,
abstracting hydrogens or adding
to double bonds.
If radicals find each other the
SOMO-SOMO reaction is
really easy. It's all downhill
in energy.
So you have to be sure they
don't find partners, and that
process is called termination of
a free-
radical chain reaction.
So you have initiation that
generates the radicals that
allow the machine to work.
Propagation, that's the cycling
of the machine.
And termination, which destroys
the machines.
Remember the New Hampshire
license plate, it says "Live
Free or Die." If the radicals
aren't free from one another,
bingo they're gone.
So that's termination.
So now how about the kinetic
order in
the amount of initiator?
You might think if you initiate
the chains twice as
fast-- if you have twice as many
machines operating--
then the reaction should be
twice as fast. The overall
rate should be twice as fast.
But that isn't true,
as you'll see here.
So the initiation, indeed,
depends on how much initiator
you have, and it has a certain
rate constant for initiation
to give those radicals.
And the rate of forming radicals
is,
therefore, first order.
It's proportional to the
concentration of the precursor.
A termination has two radicals
coming together.
It could be any radicals.
It could be the X dots coming
together, it could be R dots
coming together, or it could be
an R dot coming together
with an X dot.
All of those reactions are a
radical plus a radical-- it
will terminate.
And the rate of destroying
radicals is, of course, second
order in how many radicals there
are, because two of them
have to come together.
And at steady state, once the
thing is cranking along, the
rate of initiation, which is
this here, and the rate of
termination must be the same,
because we're in the steady
state, we're not changing the
number of machines.
So once we get to steady state
then those two will be
proportional to one another, or
the amount of R dot is
proportional to the peroxide to
the one-half power because
of that termination.
So, in fact, if the rate of the
reaction is proportional
to how many machines you have,
to the R dot, is proportional
to the square root of the amount
of initiator there,
because the destruction is
second order.
So that's an interesting
additional rate law, that when
you see that half order, in this
case it means that
there's a chain reaction going
on and
termination is involved.
So the answer is one-half order.
Now we're going to shift from
free-radical reactions toward
ionic reactions by considering
free-radical reactions that
involve ions.
The reason this is important, to
make this transition, is
because ionic reactions are so
different because they're
dependent on solvent in ways
that radical reactions aren't.
So here's another substitution
reaction where now instead of
a halogen, instead of having
Cl-Cl here, we have a
nitrogen-chlorine bond.
So we have nitrogen radicals
that can pull off hydrogen to
generate an amine, the NH bond
of an amine, and give a free
radical, just as we did before,
which then can pull
chlorine off here to make R-Cl.
So we can do a free radical
halogenation, but instead of
using a halogen we use a
chloramine.
Now this bond is about 100
kilocalories per mole, this
one is a weak bond, about 46
kilocalories per mole.
Again, like chlorine-chlorine
would be a weak bond.
And those product ones are
strong bonds.
So the first step is a little
bit exothermic, and
the last step is--
pardon me.
The first step goes from a
strong bond to a weak bond,
it's endothermic.
So that's slow.
The second one goes from a weak
bond to a strong bond,
that's exothermic.
So that one's fast. The top one
is the slow step.
But that means that this will be
the dominant species
between these two.
You'll have a lot of this so
that this rate can be equal to
this rate-- not much R dot at
any given time.
This is then what happens.
We have the free radical,
which--
pardon me, two free radicals--
can come together in this way
that one radical takes the
hydrogen from this isopropyl
group, the hydrogen here, from
the other one.
So that's the termination of the
reaction.
That's what's going to kill it.
So that's slowing the reaction
down by destroying machines.
So if we could retard this
process then we can speed up
the reaction if you don't have
termination anymore.
So this is termination by
hydrogen atom transfer--
get rid of the radicals and stop
the machine.
Now what happens if you add
acid?
Now you protonate the unshared
pair here in the amine.
And charge will keep--
remember, most of the radicals
are in this form.
But the charge, if they're both
charged,
it'll keep them apart.
And if they're apart then they
don't terminate.
So you can slow down the
termination by protonating
these free radicals.
Now let's look at these results
from 1971 on using
this reagent.
This is one step in the
reaction, the chloramine, to
substitute, to halogenate, a
long chain alcohol.
So what I graphed here is what
percent of isomers you get for
putting chlorine on this carbon
or on this carbon or
this carbon or this carbon or
this carbon.
And you can see that you don't
get more than 20% of any of
them, and you get a real dog's
breakfast mixture here of
isomers-- this is useless.
You get a very low yield of
whatever it was you wanted,
and you have to do a lot of work
to purify it.
If you do it in 50% sulfuric
acid it's pretty
much the same story.
If you do it in 60% sulfuric
acid it's a little bit better.
You get more of this.
But if you do it in 70% sulfuric
acid you get almost
all of this material--
chlorination specifically at
that position.
So isn't that a great mechanism?
By changing the solvent, by
making it a strong acid, you
can make it selective for this
one.
See the advantage of that,
obvious in synthesis.
Why?
Why when you change from--
notice 50% and 60% didn't make
much difference.
A little difference.
But going to 70% really zoomed
up on that one.
So why does changing the acid
concentration influence the
selectivity?
Notice that those amine radicals
are not
really strong bases.
It takes a very strong acid to
get most of this stuff
protonated.
To add this proton on there
takes a really strong acid.
When you get to 70% it's
almost--
pardon me.
I said exactly the wrong thing
and I apologize.
Forget what I just said for the
last 20 seconds.
The amine is a reasonable base.
It's easily protonated.
Even in weak acid this is
protonated.
But there's another base in the
system
that's hard to protonate.
And what's that?
Sebastian?
STUDENT: The alcohol.
PROFESSOR: The alcohol could be
protonated.
But you need a really strong
acid to protonate the alcohol.
So here the ROH is half
protonated.
Now if this molecule is
protonated it's hard to get
the two protonated things
together, so the reaction
slows down.
The reaction still proceeds, but
it goes with the material
that's not protonated, and it's
only half protonated.
But at 70% it's fully
protonated,
everything is like that.
Now the reaction will slow down.
So it won't be as fast. But
what?
What's the advantage?
It's hard for the charges to get
together.
So they'll stay apart to the
extent they can.
So what? Ayesha?
STUDENT: The amine would not
react...
PROFESSOR: It won't react here
near the
other positive charge.
It'll react out at the end.
It'll get a secondary hydrogen,
not the primary
one-- we've talked about that
already.
But it gets this one, not even
this one.
Isn't that a cute idea--
to use the charges to make the
thing selective.
But it only happens if you can
make both reagents be charged.
This one's easy to charge.
But this one only when you get
in very strong sulfuric acid.
I've always admired that
experiment.
So it comes down there in order
to do its reaction.
Now what I haven't shown is
reacting there.
And this is going to be related
to your next problem.
So if you use 30% sulfuric acid,
then you get a
completely different product.
Remember I went 50%, 60%, 70%.
But if you use 30% sulfuric
acid, then
you get that product.
This carbon becomes an ester or
an acid.
So this carbon gets oxidized--
the two H's are removed and
oxygen's put on.
And that probably got formed
from an aldehyde.
The first thing that probably
happened was that you changed
this CH2OH to the HC=O.
And mostly that's formed not by
a radical--
it could be formed by the
radical-chain reaction.
But probably it's not.
It's probably formed by a
HOMO-LUMO reaction, an
oxidation reaction, involving
this reagent.
Remember the original reagent
we're using--
the thing you put in is
chloramine, NCl, and at 30%
acid it's protonated.
So it's probably a reaction
between this stuff and this.
It could be the free-radical
reaction, but it's probably a
HOMO-LUMO reaction that's able
to convert this to that.
And this is that puzzle that's
your other problem for a week
from today, since we're not
having class on Monday-pardon
me, next Wednesday.
The puzzle is to propose
mechanisms to form the
aldehyde involving two steps.
A substitution, but also an
elimination reaction,
reaction with a base.
So now that substitution
reaction could either be the
radical substitution, this
mechanism going like that.
Or it could be a HOMO-LUMO
reaction.
So I've said you could get
together and
work on this in groups.
So I think you should be able to
do both these, both the
free-radical substitution and
the HOMO-LUMO, that together
with elimination, removing HX,
gives rise to the aldehyde.
So see if you can figure out why
at 30% sulfuric acid you
get a completely different
product.
I think that's enough for now.
We'll go on to this problem next
time.